les chirurgiens plastiques appartenant à
la société française des chirurgiens
esthétiques ont écrit à leur ministre de
tutelle pour que la profession soit en
quelque sorte mieux réglementer il y a
en effet une querelle d'une polémique
même entre les chirurgiens et certains
médecins un esthéticiens entre
guillemets qui n'est d'ailleurs pas une
spécialité officiellement reconnu un
problème important quand on sait
qu'aujourd'hui
de plus en plus de français et de
françaises ont recours à la chirurgie
esthétique pour leur bien être personnel
bien entendu mais aussi parfois pour
trouver ou retrouver un emploi en quête
patrick rey ce lob à la voile
l'intervention chirurgicale du contour
des yeux en ce qui me concerne consiste
à retirer le surplus de paupières qui
cette photo date de 90 monique avait
alors la quarantaine à l'époque elle
changer de travail et se sentait mal
dans sa peau
voulant rajeunir elle sait faire mode et
les paupières aujourd'hui licenciée pour
raison économique
elle est à la recherche d'un emploi
après avoir fait cette opération
esthétique je suis tout à fait confiante
pour rechercher un emploi puisque
l'image que j'ai de moi aujourd'hui dans
mon miroir me satisfait tout à fait
puisque je travaille dans le domaine de
la parfumerie et de l'esthétique la
beauté c'est le le le sujet le plus
important la jeunesse représente une
forte concurrence
une autre génération on est quand même
obligé de se battre pour rester
compétitives
du côté de l'en bochum ou femme peu
importe on est ferme pas de place pour
les vieux schnock compétences égales il
est clair qu'on est sensible aux
qualités physiques de la personne qui
est en face de nous que sa jovialité que
sa jeunesse que son allant que sa
présentation pour présenter un atout
important pour le candidat mais ce qui
reste fondamental c
essentiellement la compétence et la
motivation mais quand je me regarde dans
la glace le matin
tous les matins je me dis je suis apte
est on a compris il vaut mieux avoir
l'air jeune pour garder son emploi mais
trouver le praticien qui accomplira ce
miracle ça c'est une autre paire de
manches supprimez c'était dans le pot
lui il a opéré monique mais il n'est pas
chirurgien reconnu cet annuaire elle
s'est fait lui même sa seule arme le
bistouri et pour redonner l'éclat un
regard ainsi que donner du temps pour
cet homme n'est pas non plus chirurgien
c'est un terme à taux log nouveau cru il
fait peu d'opérations son truc à lui
c'est la médecine moderne rapide
il pose des fils pour effacer des rides
une demi-heure après c'est fini
à fait et pour faire mousser ses
nouvelles techniques certains médecins
esthéticiens n'hésite pas à faire de la
pub alors les vrais chirurgien crie au
scandale
oprean nos patients gens qualifiés font
très très peu de publicité parce que
pratiquement c'est interdit par le
conseil de l'ordre et les gens non
qualifiés font beaucoup de publicité ce
depuis hier toujours le même petit
groupe et de ce fait on considère que
les dés sont pipés car on ne lutte pas à
armes égales et le client tenace qui
veut garder son boulot a le choix entre
savants feint d'oublier charlatans
officiel pas officiel bref il y perd son
latin
sa seule référence la collègue de bureau
qui vient de se payer un nouveau look
pour garder son emploi petit budget
s'abstenir ce n'est pas remboursé
il n'y a rien en dessous de 10 mille
francs